The first order of business when using Twinmotion is to start a project and ingest the data you want to work on.
Start Twinmotion. You are greeted with a home page.
For now, go to the Templates tab and download and open the Architecture Day & Night Skies template.
Next, you need to ingest some data.
There are two fundamental approaches, one using a standard Export-Import procedure,
the other using a live link between two applications.
You will learn about both methods.
Although Twinmotion can import some file formats natively, such as FBX and escapee files among others,
there is an advantage to using the Datasmith file format.
The Datasmith file format is better suited for fully constructed scenes like you usually have in AEC.
In both cases, you will likely need to download and install the appropriate Datasmith plugin to fit your DCC application of choice.
You can do so from the Epic Games Launcher or from the Unreal Engine Twinmotion page.
There are dedicated plugins for apps like 3ds Max, Reddit, Rhino and SketchUp to name a few.
You install these plugins like any other Windows app and that gives you a new toolbar that you can now use in your DCC application.
The new toolbar looks mostly identical in all DCC apps to ensure the same workflow, look and feel, regardless of the DCC application you use.
Here I have a project in Revit that I'm planning to work on inside of Twinmotion.
It shows a community center of sorts that includes the main building, a cafe and an open theater.
Note the Datasmith menu that was added the minute I installed the plugin.
This gives me access to a new toolbar.
If all you need is a straight out export of your project, then use the Export button to export a Datasmith set to disk that you can then import into Twinmotion.
If you'd rather use the Live Link method, then you can use the other buttons.
Note the Connections button.
At this time it states that there are no connections found.
You first need to establish a connection with Twinmotion before you can synchronize the two apps.
In Twinmotion, use the Import panel to add an entry.
In the dialog that appears, choose the Direct Link tab and note how it automatically picked up your Revit project.
If you had another project opened in another app running the Live Link plugin, it would have added it to the list.
You have the option of merging objects together, based on the materials applied, or keeping them separate in a hierarchy.
There is a third option, to combine all objects into one single mesh, but that's not very practical.
I'll keep the original hierarchy for this example.
Nothing happens just yet, as all we did so far is just establish a link between the two apps.
Let's revisit Revit, and double check that the connection has indeed been made.
To see the project in Twinmotion, we only need to use the Synchronize button.
The information is processed, and the project now appears in Twinmotion.
From that point on, any change you make in Revit can be updated in Twinmotion simply by synchronizing the link again.
This example uses Revit as an originating source, but the workflow and end results would have been the same using other DCC applications.
The plugin and other apps will look very much like the one in Revit. Same buttons, same procedure.